she can hello time Shalu the girl also
come in right yes of course they can
how's it going in hello are you doing
good how are you Jim just had a very big
bowel movement so he's feeling good yeah
how big one very very student's eyes I
think that way you've gone for a long
time Natalie will talk quality they
don't talk so it was not good quality so
it's a very poor quality bed that's why
I'm more of an optimist so if the
quality is poor then I'll mention the
signs yeah to say like well the site is
good yeah yeah it was really relaxing
congratulations on the book man how long
did you work on this up a year tomorrow
okay but you know really let's face it
along a long time yes there's the stuff
it's stories that you know have been
germinating for a while where I then you
have to sit down and write it so yeah I
pitched it last spring and then I kind
of over the summer I had to write it and
pass it in and Thanksgiving and then
edit over the the holidays and then it's
all doesn't done did you like the
editing I enjoyed editing when I wrote
it did the idea of going back I kind of
liked that process because you keep
fixing it you keep like wow that was all
you look at something like that was [ __ ]
that was good yeah ah you know what's
good is the the I mean fixing fixing is
good but also good that you can't fix
like the the the deadlines right you
know what I mean like right honestly I
you know I've been waking up in a sweat
before the book came out thinking oh
it's I can't change anything I can't
change it they're like when it's done
you're like I can't change it so the
good thing is having to work with an
editor and get it done and be like okay
deadlines oh she doesn't like this okay
what is gone like you didn't like that
chapter to make a decision and just it's
that's the decision it's been made yeah
and it's over so it's kind of great and
what editors or chapters out yeah like
you know I wrote is probably I mean I
wrote like eighty five thousand words or
something man it's down to like probably
lost fifteen thousand world because it
was located the size of it sure sure
yeah so I mean chapters like stories
like this story it doesn't work it's
like maybe you've already talked about
this kind of thing so it was like you
know just a scalpel and I really like
okay yeah the editors are good at
telling you what makes sense but I
didn't like the messing with jokes at
all like oh yeah no I think I carried
Thornton was my editor at
at day Street and she was great and very
tough and I joke it in the book in the
acknowledgments I say my next book is
mean editor's for a better America like
it is and I was kind of afraid that she
would take it as a slam but she totally
knew what I was talking about right
she's like you know she would just
unabashedly send the thing back without
a bunch of writing in it I'd be like
what happened that thing's like yeah
good work sconce not there anymore you
know what you have to say - I always
correct them and I go I understand the
funny actually phrase it like that I do
and I touched the table with my one
finger like when you're lecturing
someone you're not going to take my
funny away you're not going to take my
funny lip so it's about your growing up
going off yeah and when you pitched it
do you pitch it as like a concept and
then when you have to sit down and write
it you're like okay like I had a couple
of stories involved in the pitch but now
I have to figure out yeah I got a whole
book full of stories that I have to now
do yeah yeah and it was like is it going
to be chronological is it kind of a
memoir you know because I turned in a
bunch of stories about growing up which
were funny like I tried them on stage
it's funny it's like talking about my
dad how we the classic like we grew up
different so it's stories about my dad
and the that's how I sold the book right
and then it's just early childhood so
then you got to kind of decide it's
going to be all about childhood so I
made it I kind of ended at college and
so the second half of the book kind of
takes a turn I saw you were reading it
last night I was yeah yeah I can - photo
of you yeah I'm super candid pretending
a book no just someone you know I was
reading I was just doing my reading and
so except the photo somebody snapped a
photo I don't know how I got them yeah
so I like to cover by the way - Norman
Rockwell Perrin well Ian yes with Tom's
face
ruk really in that it is actually a
total Norman Rockwell penis with my head
stuck right and this is that his real
thing where they crush out the lines of
girls names
yeah well the Sailor in it is that
amazing post cutter I imagine it's like
a sailor coming back from you know
whatever the the war but he's repeatedly
getting his girlfriend's names crossed
off oh so it's that funny thing of like
you know he's got a different girl every
in every port right right but they're
all the one yeah I could have tattooed
on his arm yeah yeah what happened - why
did they cancel that I bugged me okay
here love that show
here's the word and I don't think I
would be I can reveal all this it's live
it's live coverage the sets the secret
word live coverage there is they're
moving to live cover they want to be
live because the the primetime used to
be pre-taped everything was pre tape
right so people say live coverage you've
said that before on the radio live cover
what do you mean like uh you know the
how does that how did that knock you out
well we used to tape you know at eight
o'clock when everyone was done right
there was nothing going to you used to
come over there to Fox sure
O'Reilly was already taped wrong you
know Megan was Tate like they would pre
tape at four or five o'clock and we
would be there kind of taping after
hours from 8:00 to 9:00 now they're
taking you know Tucker's live eight to
nine the five is live nine to ten so
that's how we got bumped out is now
primetime just because of the studio
space yeah they canceled the show for
studio space
look we were X we were always a
low-budget show and were in there and
they were like now we're going live and
then the whatever extra crew is there
for breaking news which they like to go
to breaking news so they have the crews
so basically yeah it was basically the
the entire crew we were you know we were
seven people Wow when I was seven people
she's crazy for TV yes makes no sense
what and it was good like what we did
with seven people know we needed eight
guys like the show was obviously ninety
percent just what happened on the set
but still you got to line up the stories
right you got to write my intros you got
to you know you got to write your
interest you got to make fun of your
hair Lisa had to do things that doesn't
just get done yeah as a happen but for
for what it was for for the low budget
nest that was it was I thought it was
obviously I was great the show was great
I loved it you guys I hope loved coming
on
yeah but the it was essentially always
operating on borrowed time in that it
was let's make use of these this crew
it's still here you know people work
guys it's like so even if you had been
like we'll do it live at 3:00 a.m.
they're like we're not bringing a we're
not bring her right okay they're not
they're the right the kind of crew that
shoots a primetime schedule and the
control room that does primetime they
are they were we were using you know
like we were using the people who
directed all the other big projects
shows but they had extra time on their
their clock essentially right and now
it's like so they do the five live and
then Hannity is live too Hannity is
sometimes live I think I don't probably
know what you don't have a reliable
studio time until like now it's 11
o'clock at night yeah and everybody's
way over there hours or whatever yes so
9:00 to 10:00 didn't realize that so if
I was on I've never seen nine now you
know they're over there Greg Gutfeld and
Dana Perino are sitting there from 9:00
to 10:00 doing a show right it's late
you know yeah and then they got in up
there in a bigger studio so they need
more people to get the crew you know the
camera guys we had remember we would go
in there and they had the Dali camera
and no one was operating it because we
we only had like many camera people yeah
and then the guy would run over like
he'd be like he'd leave the camera
steady on us and hit run over and shoot
Andy yeah I mean yes so it really was a
because people used to joke they'd say
it's almost like a public access show
it really was right it was the it was
all done with extra people did you have
a sense though by the way the way they
Lee shoot that at night 9:00 o'clock
that does make sense that like this if
they're shooting live stuff there's no
to where they're going to shoot your
show suck you guys can't do it earlier
in the day there's no crew I'm willing
to but they know they if you look live
intro is the Machine they're live from
one show to another they got show show
shows yeah because it's live shows all
day pretty much and you try to like
fight for with any ridiculous like what
if I just get my buddies from home to
come in and operate the cameras yeah we
go there's other people that we can pull
that's what I'm doing now yeah I'm doing
I've been filling on radio which I love
yeah because radio is great yes radio is
really fun so good right you guys we
talked about your stuff it's not like I
get your point out okay we gotta go it's
called radioing yeah that's always say
we do a regular that's the proper term
that's jargon yeah that's an insider
jargon but it's no makeup I mean I
always like you know I didn't mind going
in then you get the makeup done it's
just part of your day or whatever but
then not have not doing makeup is way
better to the point of where I can't
even believe we got you guys to come
over and go into makeup and then do
redeye yes where's that much of a pain
how about Fox business we'd be great I
mean look here's what I'm doing I'm
still a thorn in their side don't think
I'm not firing off emails because I'm
over there I know I work at Fox they use
me on the shows I did
the specialist the other day i justed
Gutfeld sure so I'm very busy over there
plus any extra time I have I'm filling
it on radio it's funny that I like shows
like the specialist you're like goddamn
I have to do the shows of the people who
were doing my show we've got the
specialists 7 E K Williams and Kat Tim
and Eric Bohannon yeah and then - you
know - specialist you guys are start
thinking your specialty
I know where you have to be a specialist
in you have I have a specialty done
embarrassing they won't like the way I
say it what is the what's the specialty
making Merce douchey yeah have they done
a pro wrestling show yet it'd be good
yeah hopefully somebody in the industry
will die or something and they'll need a
pro wrestling specialist to come in and
explain what's really so they only have
specialists on things well they have the
specialist is kind of like that you know
and they get people there's people in
media and whatever you know I'm a
specialist I'm a barber shop or a price
I'm a professional barber court
barbershop quartet singer yeah I'm a
mean dad that we put that in there
actually because we were able to plug
the book and have a specialty as well
yeah and then we just talk about the
issues of the day so it's kind of a fun
way to get through yeah I'm the last
professional broadcaster that's a
specialty yeah right yeah yeah I'll say
thanks thanks around three stalkers I
appreciate your honor to watch you watch
you work
but I'm digital now I'm on radio but
we're also we do Facebook live the shows
because you guys do there's cameras here
right right over there so we get things
oh there we are yeah so weird we've been
getting a lot of viewers on Facebook
live I'm holding onto the red-eye fans
you know giving them something to - to
have and then you come over and they're
like oh my god Sam is here it is fun
doing the radio show when like you see
the people on Twitter that are although
like the red-eye loyalists that of yeah
followed Tom and Andy Andy does it with
okay over to the radio thing
yes and so my goal is to recreate the
spirit of redeye and right now I'm doing
a lot of radio so that's I'm not going
to sneeze at that it's great boom radio
yeah and then we got digital we got you
know we got ahead we had a half a
million viewers
late night on on the red-eye you know do
you think I can get that on online if
we yeah so if I do a show you did it on
digital formats and you didn't have a
million people watching regularly why
not save a huge success
if you huge success but if I can do that
then they'll be happy and then oh my god
yeah
and yeah there's always TV there's more
to be had so instead of sitting around
and waiting oh give me another show
right put me on a panel show or whatever
I'm trying to and this is what you know
when people are texting me like what's
wrong with you what are you doing over
there um you know or people being angry
at Fox for canceling the show I'm like
I'm getting uh what do you call I get
you know some get going I get going some
get up get to wait when the going gets
tough the topic oh it right and you're
saying the going got tough it did go
time for good tell Tom to get going
getting going
yes so I'm broadcasting over there and
I'm trying to build a show and I think
that there's not you know FNC hasn't had
enough stuff online you know the general
says what I'd only 100 percent online if
you could get a digital show FNC
something you're talking about three
different people oh good you could get a
digital show to get five hundred
thousand people they'd be like way more
impressed than they were for Reta that
you would be like a big star then as a
poet because that's that's huge digital
numbers yeah look what this guy did
right with with the internet which I'm
sure still mystifies some people you
know how long did you host it for two
years when Roger Ailes left do you think
guy seemingly so much stuff has changed
since he left yeah I mean I plus al
Reilly see no one could see coming but
also like the channel or the planet um
no before what do you would he get buddy
yeah but he stepped out and gotcha yeah
the death did the fact because he'd
already stepped out yes I did O'Reilly
leaving in Hannity maybe there's so many
changes do you think that you you were
just kind of part of that shake-up
well you know that too you know there
was so much going on over there and but
also I think more than anything it's
like the change in because you could see
you know you know what's happening in
cable news things it used to be
do you remember like even 10 years ago
it was just even the primetime was like
extra like hey let's just let's put some
opinion programming on at night right
you know what I mean and then it became
the biggest thing so now all the biggest
shows are the opinion shows and you know
that they're on in primetime so
they can't really aren't any news on
cable like none of the none of the shows
in primetime are straight news every
even like right Anderson Cooper's of the
world it would probably try to portray
themselves as more straight news his
opinion all the way six o'clock were
told a little bit over at fnc was i want
to call it six o'clock straight news six
- you know bret baier breve it was a
great show
Shep is straight news shut up is
straight news I like Shepard Bret Baier
and they get huge you know so the thing
is it's always that there's there it's
it's beef up the opinion program beef up
the thing you know so we were you know
we get swept up in the whirlwind of that
and like I said we were always the
little guy so it's amazing that we got I
keep telling people who are angry it's
true be angry but my whole tenure there
was extra time anyway they were like
let's take this guy who's like always
here he's getting annoying yeah he's you
know he's filling in for Greg all the
time he obviously wants his show let's
let him run it for a while you know
right because so it was essentially
maybe I was on borrowed time the whole
time who knows right but yeah you know
it was good to be it was good to do it
while I did it are you taking notes
watching Tucker Carlson climb that
ladder as quickly as anybody's ever
climbed it I mean he's amazing but he
was always amazing yeah like listen go
back to that the famous that thing with
Jon Stewart uh-huh yeah Jon Stewart
destroys Tucker calls it destroyed him
back then he was always amazing and even
if even if you did admit even if you did
think that Jon Stewart destroyed him he
still looked completely unshaken by it
I've never seen that man look shaking
whether he's winning or losing a debate
it's like it doesn't nothing bothers him
yeah how's he doing in the ratings she's
doing very well yes at one point and I
mean I don't know what the I never know
that like what numbers because I'm not
obsessed with that kind of a thing yeah
I'm just kinda like he's the best I like
this you have an office there yes you do
okay hey Andy you and Andy shared office
know Andy's down the hall and so it's
it's funny because there's still the
skeleton it's Andy's still there and I'm
there but they almost everyone who was
on red I almost all the seven people
moved to other shows and things the
camera guys the yeah they're all doing
camera but then the actual staff you
know like Christine are booked issues
working in the documentary unit so they
they're there
all in different places oh I see them
around and so so what anyway Andy is is
doing what he did before he's at his
desk and he he feels he does other shows
and things like that what did he do any
other shows he's do the same type of
thing yeah he gives his his take on
things oh he does okay thanks so you
guys are on the contract I'm sure if
you're under contract for awhile if I
don't I just you know so you make
something happen before that's up and
you'll get another one yeah exactly
well I'm not I mean it's not just that
I'm under contract that they got to find
something for me they do like me yeah
yeah no no what I'm saying is I have an
ability it's me but from the business
point of view the businesses didn't
never really care about the people you
know I mean they say if you're there
they're gonna okay let's see if you can
come up with something else or what come
up with something yes for you and they
do loved it I mean it's a great I love
it over there they have their people
late lately they're good - they're their
people in there they're contributors and
stuff like that so they they're always
looking to use them and so I'm just
trying to be extra useful I'm like you
know I'm I'm letting everyone know what
I want to do plus I probably love that
you came out with a book and it's like
not some weird fox news tell it's here's
some stories from when I was growing up
this is crazy
it's a non-political book right it's
great I think it's time for listen I
shouldn't even like tell me guys go
ahead I'm sick of I'm sick of talking
about this nonsense
what nonsense the book the president oh
I don't know much about what it is I
think it's like you know I wouldn't even
mind if I had to talk about these issues
all day and like James Comey but it let
me talk about it because that's my job
talking about the issues but why are you
why is everyone talking about it on
every show it's so ridiculous meaning
that like shows that aren't even these
aren't political shows as a comedy show
- this type of show it - that type of
show everybody is just talking about
yeah well you know what it is I think
it's peak one of the reasons is because
he is an entertainer and so like this
thing even morning towards me it's not
not if you have entertainer he is an
entertainer but like Donald Trump being
an entertainer first before he was
president means that like this whole day
like political news now also gets
categorized as Hollywood gossip
technically yeah and gets categorized as
Business News over here because he was
a real-estate guy over here and he also
you know whether you want to say he dumb
things down or just his way of speaking
is more like the common person it really
makes it seem like anybody can
understand what he's talking about
but did you hear about the whole thing
with the FBI director that is that's
where you got crazy right yeah didn't he
see something like Trump said something
yeah well that's it really is endlessly
Hornets of a little things about you
know this uh I don't even come on like I
can't even fall this cult coffee thing
like it was on I'm like maybe I could
yet why is it Co Fifi why does a CEO V
Fe Fe Cobb CC confusing I mean that's so
I don't know you put a European twist
everything yeah I read something a cafe
and you know in the Francis I did hear
somebody say cough sakes hey and I was
like now with khofifah cuz they say
maybe more correct confuse I know I
wouldn't put the e on the end that's I'm
American so I say Co fief like it's an e
like silent e you know who ya and into a
Casey's yeah yes comfy Nevada I do not
silent E no come on
I do remember conjunction junction
what's your function yeah he was one of
those he was a superhero who put a on
the end of everything
Oh wake up Fifi yeah but a bill becomes
a law who wasn't a fan of that song I
mean I can rule didn't know I was a fan
I'm awesome did it existed you remember
conjunction junction what's your
function of course I remember it that
wouldn't be like oh that's a great song
I've been awesome to now anointing up
words and phrases and such right I don't
remember what the hell decide just
remember that are fairly ineffective
now that I was a boy see if it's if all
you remember is conjunction junction
what's your function
no first I don't it's the other part
yeah the answer follows but it's a fact
I can remember clear a little moment of
it you know the fact that I can remember
any of it is a miracle there's a man in
a kilt okay it's not a miracle I mean
it's completely you started up good
music
stuff through the cool words and phrases
and claws oh that's what a conjunctions
403 favorite cars that get most of my
job alright I don't remember you think
this is like a good song nice it sound
like a good soft but you remember it
I do remember yes we all remember you a
fan travis of the song no no it's not a
great song it's a great song who is that
singing - what is that like John
Hendricks or some it's obviously a jazz
great sing in the tune he's full of
talents but he probably did not get like
credited for it I mean they gave him a
day rate I know who sung the song
because I'm sure he's got conjunction
Joshin yeah let's look up because right
who sang conjunction junction yeah yeah
there's no way you didn't melt around
they got the whole house rocks a formal
house rock they hired the top people
right top of their profession well yeah
they needed credibility so that people
would remember the great lessons like
conjunction what's your function Jack
Sheldon Jack shells I thought right Jack
Sheldon of course there are great bebop
West Coast Jags dressed trumpeter sing I
mean it obviously is incredible yeah but
um here's the music director on the Merv
Griffin Show a little trivia thanks or
that you just read it off the thing I
knew that but you fit I guess I said
that before in the song I meant I didn't
realize that yeah you don't know that
Roger Ailes used to book the stand-up
for for uh Mike Douglas really Wow
no he was the talent stand a Booker for
Mike Douglas
oh [ __ ] like let me ask you when they
have a talent book I didn't remember the
Mike Douglas show as far as than having
stand-ups on four guys four interviews
are doing stand-up comedy and of like
David Brenner they had a stand-up slot
you know and because I used to watch it
yeah cuz daytime TV I didn't stay up
late so I didn't see people on The
Tonight Show but I would see David
Brenner and I mean he's the only guy I
remember from the property line yeah
Robert Klein and send some
Impressionists you know other people
that maybe little remember yeah rich
little but I would see them on the
daytime shows right and they would do
you know or who's the guy who played the
Riddler remember that guy oh yeah
Porsche ocean gorson right or straight
or like that well
um where I love the Mike Douglas show it
was sloppy yes it was like [ __ ] it was
flawed yes like Dick Cavett like they
would do it was a great interview did
the Jackson five and it was such an
awkward shitty interview but it was so
great because he's like I hear one of
you is a prankster yeah and then like
one of the kids was like yeah it was
like such a dead but it was there and
just but it was such a legitimate
conversation it was great it's been
amazing those silences you never have
silences on TV and you never it's just
the host hit the power I mean guys like
a you know Peter Falk like coming on
crashed on in an afternoon show probably
trash from the night before you know
just showing up and you could and even
as a kid I was like I think they're
inebriated you know actors right obvious
it's also not special to hear
celebrities talk anymore
back then like when a celebrity did an
interview oh my god I'm seeing someone
not in the roles I normally see the
moment they're actually talking so it
kind of meant more now you don't give a
[ __ ] kid we always see celebrities
yappin about everything everywhere I go
it doesn't mean anything anymore
yeah it was still fun back then here how
awkward and lousy something like they
just didn't have to be interesting yeah
you had a good point in your blood Hanks
brother not you Jim
I read your book you had no good points
in it but Tom and it was well Jim will
love this book as it is it's it's about
it's funny because Gutfeld when I did it
was talking to him about it he was like
this is about the 70s it really is like
one right dart when I sat set to write
it I wanted to write a book about the
70s because no one gets it right I
wanted to have a funny book of stories
where people say oh that's the way it
was because whenever you turn on like a
you know like an HBO show that's set in
the 70s or any movie or anything vinyl
it's yeah it's like everyone's got
bell-bottoms and they're like hey man
and their beads and everything and
that's not the way it looked like there
were no hippies in my town right
you know 1974 I was walking around with
a crew-cut
everybody looked like you know Mayberry
and it was like the 50s he's from
Brooklyn by the way yeah yeah exactly
where you live
Norwood Massachusetts so it was a good
American small town went to the parade's
flags etc like it was a it was old
America you know
and the 70s weren't really there in most
of America it was like New York and LA
yeah I get it but and you talk about
that though like you kind of credited to
your parents and parents of other people
obviously that you were raised by the
50s because that was the mentality that
your parents had as they were raising
you so do you think that like the
generation now like the Millennials that
get criticized as much as they get
criticized for do you think it's because
Gen Xers and the generation before them
are the ones raising them like this is
what's been instilled in these kids and
that's why they have the behaviors that
they have because that's what they're
being raised with but yeah I think so
and I don't blame I mean I guess people
do they blame Millennials people don't
like your way you think yeah that's like
you can't really blame them there in the
world of today right um but I don't know
the thing is there's nothing in the and
you probably notice there's nothing in
the book that says you know it was
better the way that nothing now this is
the way you have to raise your kids and
I hate this but you know it to me it was
like oh let's just say the way I grew up
exactly right and without teaching a
lesson or like less it you'll take away
from it there's you hate always that's
different like I feel like there's a
there's a new trend in in the world of
memoy where where there always has to be
like it has to be wrapped in a lesson
and the lesson is literal and it's right
there and it says so what I learned from
this was and that comes up like every
few pages and you're like I just I just
like the story because we're taught that
there has to be a beginning a middle and
a conclusion like everything's a sitcom
yeah it has to be like an Act one and I
am on that x-ray how much sex in the
city it's like I guess you know at the
end of the show typing right I don't
know not always that yeah I don't know
but it's that like wrapping it up like
right I learned on this situation you
know and this she always would learn at
the end of every day it has a mark in a
completion I don't give a [ __ ] what the
character learned book which allowed me
to form the takeaway yes my god you
learn nothing is just funny have you any
how about you to learn any I don't need
to learn something every time I enjoy it
I don't watch TV just to get energy to
give education I watch Discovery or go
online I don't go on honey I don't watch
TV to get an education that's what the
Internet's for yeah
these are watching educational videos
but octopi
we were discussing them before yeah very
smart animal oh yeah the you know they
cut off their tentacles while they're
still alive to make calamari sometimes I
don't care for that because why because
it's it's cruel it hurts very cool
imagine somebody cut off your arm but
it's why it makes it for fresher column
by a shorter dopey customer is fresh
probably you think it'd be the same yeah
I don't know if those squiggly things
really matter that much so I think it's
okay to chop them up and eat them it's
like how a worm just regenerates it's
just like it's just an appendage wiggle
I should I still a pain receptor so I
don't know though like do you see what
how can they have pain they're at the
bottom of the sea that's true to see
it's so crushing you ever go down the
bottom of the sea yes you don't know but
the the the the octopus can be down in
the inky depth sure and they're covered
with with um you know I always try to
stress to my daughters how when you go
down how heavy that water is right
that's why you get crushed to death down
there everybody under the sea thinks
it's better down where it's wetter but
it's not yeah it's not it's not better
down there but I think for them you know
chop chop chop I don't think it's I
don't think they're going through agony
there they do they stay square miles
watch iso footage is awful oh yeah but
it might just be might just be like like
you know like a nerves like we're just
like well yeah you know you just fidget
a little bit right I think things in the
sea you know we got a door otherwise
somewhere yeah they're slimy and you
know you get they get a hook in their
throat it is not pleasant to go fishing
and even they they're like oh I'm a good
fisherman I throw the back end yeah
after putting a hook in there - yeah
there's got to be a better way like with
an lash cuz I'm gonna rock yeah exactly
I mean you didn't murder him you salted
yeah salt with a deadly weapon like
think of the hook in your throat right
yeah it's not good and then every minute
that they're above water it's like I'm
pushing your head beneath water because
they can't breathe and I mean picked up
by that you might just supporting your
full body weight with a hook in your
throat and then squiggling rod stay
still if it was in my throat just like
that yeah I'd be like I don't want to
try to brunch everybody - yeah yeah dumb
fishing
stupid foot holes but even with this
method even with this method of slashing
up these idiots most a lot I don't know
most I don't know in the statistics but
a lodger that a lot of vegetarians still
eat fish they'll be like no no I'm a
vegetarian but I'll eat fish yeah and it
segment is that less cruel well there
there are so many reasons for their
vegetarianism and I think there's a lot
of people who are just you know they're
in a kind of a diet that they they'd
rather not know how every yeah yeah but
they're not about the cruelty wing right
it's a slippery slope I don't know if
you should go down there but I'm
obviously Pro using animals octopuses
show much of the pain related behavior
seeing vertebraes how do they know what
are the octopus tell them they said
screwing and protecting injured body
parts this is why you Clay's they can
tell people are like dolphins are very
close to human if they are not those
aren't even sort of close to humans well
they're pretty smart though I do I mean
I lost time a dolphin build a house let
off hand wait a minute did you ever see
The Oprah Winfrey narrated probably the
overview narrative documentary on on
life and now shows these dolphins you
wrecking you watch weird stuff me
exactly I Louis listen hurts all of us
cereal no it's I mean I would have used
two different I would have used Morgan
payment or something I'd like a cereal
yeah I didn't know what the magazine
just gone now look it's it's an amazing
video that you can find in all your
favorite search engines ask GSN
whichever you want exactly but the the
dolphins it's a certain group of
dolphins that know they figured out this
thing to do where they swim in a circle
around fish to freak them out and then
they jump out of the circle they're like
let me get out of this crazy circle of
dolphins and they jump out and the other
dolphins laughing wait with their mouths
open and get free fish jumping into
their mouths it's the most amazing
lyrics or super dad smarter than things
that you do on you know what I mean no
no no wait but like but like if you get
a group of people together they're like
we don't have restaurants so we have to
figure out how to eat like humans would
figure that out so much quicker than
dolphins and it like okay dolphins just
knew it does they probably you have to
figure it out they're just born with
that knowledge really well then they
should be born with the knowledge to not
be farmed so that we can ride them and
resorts well I'm you know there's oh
they're so smart like they can't walk
they don't have hand I mean a lot of
things they can't do physically yeah
they do a lot with what think critically
I'm saying that I don't know if you you
would figure out that little trick I
would have you would have a super hungry
yeah
there's no restaurant you have to figure
something out yeah I don't know if I
would think to circle the fish and make
them jump out they jump out and the
other picture like there you have the
mouth open and they're just happily
receiving fish jumping is not like it's
not like it when a person jumps like
it's like there's not that much that
fish can do so getting them to jump is
easier ya know the fish are dumb I'm
saying the Dragons are smart that is the
care to the dumb fish proof of it and
Oprah told me this no other dolphins
figured this out it's just like this
it's just this group adult all in super
smart these are the super smart ones
well they're just you know these are the
kind of things that dolphins do in their
spare time they think of their own
little tricks this isn't even if this
were people it would be like a game this
is the most violent group of dolphins it
may not definitely yeah these fish
police and horrible dolphins but seeing
those fish jump to landing changes and
make also so happy so happy I mean I
would I would like to see that too are
you doing any book signings book
signings yeah I did one I did a you know
my book release was at Caroline's on
Broadway
okay I'm Broadway yeah way oh we did a
show with Joe DeVito and Dave Smith the
and it was great those guys are great
and I'm going back to Norwood my
hometown
hey do a book signing I'm going to be at
the Walpole mall wall pull and the so
we'll see how the hometown people do I
mean it's all about it's about Norwood I
need everyone in my hometown to read
this book but other people too but I
know you doing it the book signing
next week the the Father's Day weekend
I'll be at bonds and Noble in Walpole
well that's I mean and it's good for all
those like outside of Boston
Massachusetts towns I mean it's all I'm
assuming very very relatable yes and I
think you know people will email me who
are from the 50s like they really were
born in the 50s all this is my childhood
and then someone be like I was born in
82 this is my child so it's kind of got
that you know it's really any it's
before cable like that's the essential
thing that's when the media started
mixing us all together with the same
videos and the same whatever like the
idea of
so much that I wanted to capture of the
that just kids world you know what I
mean like when when when you were a kid
you didn't have adults around you a lot
of your life right you know my mother
was all at home during the day but I was
a little naughty boy running on the
neighborhood you were what was your town
which we're venison New Jersey yeah so
it's like it's northeast it's lazytown
Jim's childhood was the reason why
adults had to start being around their
kids all the time yeah I'm the rest they
stepped in yeah
so what look it was it was more
dangerous back then and you were
definitely more vulnerable to predators
but people acted like it was less that
way so your parents let you go out we
would just go in the woods right and we
would spend the day in the woods between
you know the mall and you know it's just
one right and they were blowing each
other no because that's a I mean it's
John I know it was Jim's
clean up running gyms great pass well
your friends you share and did I mention
in the thing about there were so many
things you have to leave out because
they seem kind of seedy because there's
stuff that you know you're like I can't
I can't write about that why well like
you guys were talking early that you
know the great conversation this morning
which I don't know if it's been done to
death but you're talking about the Bill
Maher thing and sure sure there was a
thing I wanted to put the book but this
it's just weird like you don't want to
have any instances of like it you'd have
to spent you'd have to spend so much
time explaining it but there was like
there's a lot of playground stuff and
kids misbehaving and kids being bullying
and things like that but there was a one
of the kids said the n-word while we
were playing like in the sprinkler like
last one ins and you know and yeah you
know that kind of thing and kids didn't
even know what it meant at the time we
were so young and my mother stuck her
head out the window and she's like hey
hey don't say that word bad word and
then went back in but there was an end
right it's the first one in well it was
exactly no but it was like
matter-of-fact like she didn't call us
aside and give us a civil rights lesson
or what like she didn't overdo it my mom
no bad words shitty word you should say
it nothing over the weekend my mom told
me the first time she heard the word
when she was growing up was from I when
she was [ __ ]
there was there was a history show but
it was from there's her mom who she was
like young and there in the car and that
is a black person outside the car and my
mom was just kind of looking at him he'd
never seen a black person before I guess
they grew up but they were just moving
to Detroit from Kentucky so she was
looking at this black guy and then her
mom looks at her and she goes that's an
n-word but they don't like to be called
that like I said she was combining
racism with being trying to give a
polite lesson I mean I think at the time
where she was from the south she would
probably be considered very liberal yeah
based on that explanation she put in
they they don't like to because they
don't like to be held there that's very
very liberal progressive back in those
days right right yeah did you I did
anybody put in here writing a book you
would well it wasn't your mother who it
was a friend of your mother who said
that no it's my mom's mom who said that
- okay your mom's on but if you're
running book and you said that you'd
have to be like oh now I'm like my
grandma wasn't ready like you know and
then someone's gonna write a blog like
boom interesting right you know samurai
was grandmother was a virulent racist
and they go I just take that one quote
out of your book and then yeah you want
to be see that would be a great little
thing to write in a book but then you'd
have to follow it up with like two pages
of explanation about why you know that
the time and you know whatever so you're
like no but that would be crazy if you
just say like I learned the lesson and I
didn't use the word after should maybe I
should have put in the book but you know
what the thing is it's so we live in an
upside-down world where everyone's
losing their minds mm-hmm and this is
why Bill Maher has to do a 30-minute
monologue and it's like I get it what do
you who doesn't get what you're talking
about
we're all pretending to not understand
in all this stuff so you know sometimes
it's like well leave that and go on to
the next thing or whatever but it's the
the it that moment would have been like
a perfect thing to talk about about the
70s that no one made a big deal out of
it it probably would have made the word
magic to some of these kids and then
they would have used it more but then
they don't know it was like okay we
can't because you know that lady just
heard it yeah because then also what
your lesson in the bar you advocating
that we should use it or we shouldn't
use it or it was good then or with
and then you know we were going through
a lot of bad times then about an IED
okay I forget a shut up forget I want
talk about it's like just in its the you
you got us you read a story and the
thing is that young people they don't
know about the world because no one has
told them so I'm saying like oh this is
what me and my brother were afraid of my
dad I mean that can kind of rock the
world of a 21 year old because they're
like really what do you mean and you're
like then if I sit down and explain it
to them I'm like that's the way our life
was we were like our dad was scary to us
rez was our dad as was the kids there
was kids in the playground our lives
yeah but the thing is yeah our dad he
was an authority figure but you know we
were like yeah I love my dad but you
never said it you really how is that
scary guy
you know I did I did where I was told
that kind of thing so I wanted it down
on paper and it's like read this oh
that's that guy that was his life yeah
no one talked like no one says you know
they don't tell the truth about write
about the world right yeah you know I
cuz I grew up my dad was similar to
yours in the sense that he was he was
appointed that's insulting to both of us
exactly I know here's here's what he was
a mean dad but it was like because that
was his job that was his role and in
hindsight like I can see that he didn't
enjoy it most of the time he just knew
that in order to do this properly he had
to be this person to lay down the law
and like it you're right
everything is everything has changed
that is way and it was common then yes
even when I was growing up in the in the
80s but it's become it's become much
less you just don't see it you see like
a households where it's non non yelling
households yeah we don't we don't yeah